- Welcome back.
We're here with Elisabeth Moss, y'all!
Give it up.
(crowd cheering and clapping)
Our next guest is a very talented musician
from a musically-gifted family.
Her debut album is called
"The Hardest Part,"
and off that album, her new single is
"Noah (Stand Still)".
Cool title.
You can find both wherever
you get your music,
and you can find her in
the back of the most fun
Uber ride ever.
(upbeat music)
(music continues)
Well,
I'm going to have to know
how that night ended.
(Elisabeth laughs)
And I'm disappointed in
every Uber driver I've
ever had at this point.
Say hello to Noah Cyrus!
(audience cheering)
(jazzy music playing)
(cheering and music continue)
[Kelly] I love it!
Well, so have y'all ever met before?
- No! We have not. - No.
- [Kelly] Y'all never met?
- [Noah] It's so nice to meet you!
- I'm a very big fan.
- [Kelly] Oh my god.
I know. This rock and roll
vibe you've got going on.
(singing) Hey.
(Normal voice) I like it.
So, real quick, Noah
What company? How do you
get that Uber driver?
- [Noah] Oh, my.
- Like, that ... What happened there?
- Okay, so
my friend actually, like,
knew Vic before I did. I was like ...
- [Kelly] Vic.
- I would see Vic on my
friend's Instagram stories,
and I would be like, "This looks insane."
- [Kelly] Fun.
- Insane! Insane.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- And I was in need of a ride one night,
and Vic, Vic was there for me,
and it was ...
- [Kelly] With a party!
- [Noah] It was, it
was pretty nuts. Um ...
- [Kelly] It's crazy!
- [Noah] You know, at
the end of this video,
I don't think you can hear it,
but he says, "Get on my shoulders."
(Noah laughs)
- [Kelly] You're like,
"You know what ... "
- [Noah] And we're in the
McDonald's drive-through.
(Kelly laughs)
- [Kelly] What?!
- [Noah] Yeah. So that ... Yeah.
- Someone should tell Vic
you can't say that anymore.
(Kelly laughs)
That's amazing!
- Yeah. Yeah. We were ...
- [Kelly] He looks like a fun experience.
I feel like that should be, like, a thing
when people come to L.A.
- [Noah] It's an experience.
- Like, "Oh, you've got
to take a ride with Vic."
Yeah.
- Maybe not the shoulders. But yes.
- [Noah] It's great.
(Elisabeth and Kelly laughing)
So wait. So your debut album
is called "The Hardest Part"
which is such a cool title, by the way,
just from musician to musician.
I just love how you're
like, "What is this about?
This could be about so many things."
So why did you want to call it that?
- [Noah] Well, it is about so many things.
It was kind of the hardest
part of a lot of things.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Um, "The Hardest
Part" is the title track
of the record, as well.
Um.
Which kind of touches on
the subject of going home
and getting older and kind of
finding yourself
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Noah] As an adult.
And also touched on, um ... I'm about ...
Um, in December will be
two years into recovery
of off Xanax, uh, addiction, and so I ...
- [Kelly] Oh, wow! I didn't know that!
- [Noah] Okay. Yeah!
So I, um ...
- No.
- [Noah] I touch on that
in the album, and, um ...
- [Kelly] Hey, that's so
important that you're talking
about that because a lot
of people are addicted
to, like, pharmaceuticals in general.
Like, that's an important
thing that people
do not talk about.
- It's ... it was
an extremely
challenging
couple of years.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And, um, I think, in the pandemic,
a lot of us can agree.
We all were forced into isolation
and um
just really confronting and dealing with
all of our anxieties, and our depression,
and mental health, and when
addiction was in the picture
with me, I just furthered
my self into that.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I was also really in
love at the time of the, um,
pandemic, and I think I was
just as addicted to that person
as I was the substances,
and when substance abuse, I think,
is in the mix of a relationship,
it creates a pretty toxic environment.
- [Kelly] Yes. Yeah.
- [Noah] And so I touch on
a lot of the hardest part
of a lot of things on this album.
This album, without a doubt,
saved my life, absolutely.
It gave me so much structure and um ...
- And a vessel, right? And an outlet.
- [Noah] Yeah. That's exactly
what I was going to say.
An emotional outlet at a
time I really needed it.
- Yeah.
- [Noah] Um, and I mean,
I think everyone agrees
how healing music is.
- [Kelly] Oh, my gosh.
- And as a musician and I
think even just as listeners
and, um,
music is just healing and
can offer you a friend.
- [Kelly] Such a great connector.
- [Noah] Yeah. Yeah!
- To not feel alone.
- That's the greatest gift ever
when you put a song on
because you're like,
"Look, I just need to,
like, have a minute."
And you have, like, a
song or whatever you go.
Do you have a song that you
go to when you're like ...
- Oh, gosh.
- I go to pretty much
anything Annie Lennox.
- There's so many. There's so many.
I mean, for me, it's
just that expression that
sometimes I can't put into words.
You know?
I can't do what you do. Or you do.
- Well, I can't do what you do, so ...
- [Kelly] Yeah. Me neither.
- And I can't do what you do.
- [Kelly] Me neither.
I can't do that either.
- [Elisabeth] I can't write
like that or sing like that,
so for me, it's sometimes
if you can't put something
into words or express
something, the perfect song
that one of you has done and written
can really express something
for me, and obviously
for so many people around the world.
- Yeah. I have, like,
artists more so I go to
that I'm like, "Oh, I need this."
- [Elisabeth] Oh, yeah.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- [Kelly] Um, I love this,
too, that your latest single,
it's with your dad, right?
- [Noah] It is. Yeah.
- [Kelly] And it's "Noah (Stand Still)"?
- [Noah] It is.
- [Kelly] So where does that come from?
Is that from him telling you to be still?
- Yeah. So I have "stand
still" here on my arm,
and so does my dad.
I'm actually covering my pinkie because
I have all of these
nails but one, um, so ...
- [Kelly] I've done that
on this show! (laughs)
- [Noah] I'm just going like this
for the remainder of our ...
- I've totally done that
with my ring finger one time,
and I was like, "I'm going
to look like I'm flashing
gang signs." I'm like ...
Because I was trying to hide it.
I didn't even notice!
You're so good.
I was looking at your
cool tats, so you're good.
- [Noah] Oh, thank you.
So, no. "Stand still" has just been
around through generations
of my dad's side of my ...
His grandfather, his dad.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Um, passed down to him,
and has kind of shared that advice of
when you don't know what
to do, just stand still.
I took a trip to see my dad,
um,
I think around August 2020,
which was couple months before I really
committed to recovery.
Um.
And we stood up on his hill in Nashville,
and Nashville's just
such a peaceful place.
- Beautiful, too. Yeah.
- [Noah] And he had me take my shoes off
and put my feet in the grass
and really get connected to home,
and he said, "Noah, just stand still.
Like, breathe in the air.
Just stand still, and
get connected back to
who you really are. You know?
None of the rest of this matters.
Like, let's just be here, me and you."
And we had such an amazing moment.
- Oh, wow.
- [Noah] that I hadn't
had in such a long time,
and he has no idea.
Well, I mean, he will now
because he's watching this at home.
Hi dad!
(Kelly laughs)
Um, but he really had no
idea, I think, at the time.
- [Kelly] The impact.
- As a parent, as parents, you can see
your child is struggling,
but he didn't know,
really, how much I really
needed to hear that be
reminded of that at that time.
- That's so cool that you're
able to like, have that
in your family.
Y'all are musical, and you have that gift
to be able to share together.
That's really special.
I challenge everyone to find
something, um, that's just
artistic because it comes
out in a different way,
and it's a good release, I think.